Film Courage: You know we talked about this
earlier and I hope you’re okay talking about
this again?
Larry Wilson: Yes.
Film Courage: Okay...about not going to college
or going to junior college and not finishing
[a 2-year degree] and still having confidence
and being able to believe in yourself even
if somebody in an executive’s suit sitting
on the other side of this really nice Mahogany
desk with their arms folded tells you you’re
not okay.
But also knowing that you are [okay].
Where does that come from, because I don’t
think that is something innate.
You probably develop it over time, wouldn’t
you say?
Larry Wilson: Yeah...and it was an issue for
me...there is no doubt about it.
When I became a studio executive at Paramount
working most closely with Jeff Katzenberg.
All of the sudden there was this (as these
bizarre trends happened and you don’t quite
understand where they come from and then would
go away), but all of the sudden it became
very important to hire people in development
positions who had a Harvard education and
I was working with a couple of them and they
also went to the school of Machiavelli I guess
and had read and reread The Art of War and
strategically on that level they could take
me out, okay.
But I thought about it and I thought I’ve
loved movies since I can remember.
And while I was terrible in school (I was
a terrible student), my mom loved reading.
She taught me the love of reading, so I had
that on my side.
But what I really had on my side was if I
loved a movie, I LOVED a movie, I loved it!
And I realized pretty quickly that “the
movies,” the movie business, it was not
a business meant for Harvard grads.
And I could read a script and say “This
is a movie” and say it with as much confidence
as possible and mean it and believe it.
But I was up against this...and my own inferiority
complex sometimes...about not having been
a good student and having barely gotten out
of high school.
It would work on me sometimes.
But one day after I had been completely creamed
in a development war with one of these Harvard
grads, Jeff Katzenberg took me aside and he
said “Larry, you need to learn to be a straight
player in a crooked game.
I’m not here for you to out-manipulate anyone.
You’re sitting with me and you’re sitting
beside me here because when you love something,
you love it.
And when you read a script and you love it,
you’re going to make sure that everyone
else loves it, too.
And that’s what I like in you.
And that’s why you’re valuable to me.
Stop trying to be a studio executive.
Be a guy who can read a script or watch a
movie and get excited the way you get excited.”
And that was a huge shot in the arm of confidence
that I took away.
I owe Jeff Katzenberg for a lot of things
that he wouldn’t even be aware of.
But that was a big one because he told me
“Just be yourself and use this passion for
movies and this love for movies and make that
your calling card.
Don’t try to be ‘A Player.’
You’re not good at it.
You’re horrible at it.”
Which I am, because I wear everything on my
sleeve.
Ask my wife, yeah...